ciao maryners e benvenuti in un
nuovissimo video
oggi parliamo di mamme ma in un modo
particolare
oggi vi farò scoprire quelli che sono i
significati più nascosti delle frasi che
dicono più spesso le nostre mamme ti
avevo detto di sistemare camera tua che
cosa è questo eh e questo e questo qui e
quello non hai sistemato
camera tua e non pensare assolutamente
che lo faccia io per te adesso sai
cosa faccio io prendo e me ne vado da
questa casa
voglio proprio vedere se sopravvivete
senza di me non me ne andrò mai da
questa casa quindi siate riconoscenti
per quello che faccio per questa
famiglia senti signorina
questa casa non è un albergo va bene non
puoi entrare e uscire agli orari che
preferisci
e non è neanche giusto che tu non dia
una mano e che ti faccia servire perché
io non sono una cameriera è pronto è
pronta la cena allora che dobbiamo fare
è pronto vieni subito a dare una mano
apparecchia non so fai qualcosa e no non è
pronto è quasi pronto quando io avevo la
tua età mi comportavo come te forse
anche peggio ma non te lo dirò mai
perché io ti devo dare il buon esempio
casa mia regole mie
finché vivrai sotto questo tetto fai
quello che ti dico io quando te ne
andrai continuerai a fare quello che ti
dico io perché io sono tua madre tu non
esci punto e basta tutti i giorni al
telegiornale non si sentono altro che
disgrazie io non voglio che ti succeda
niente e quindi preferisco che tu stia a
casa qui con me e fammi capire se i tuoi
compagni si buttano giù da un burrone cosa
fai lo fai pure tu ho paura che i tuoi
compagni ti possano influenzare
negativamente hai portato un cane in
casa mia ma sei pazzo dico io hai due minuti
due minuti per portarlo fuori di qui a
casa mia gli animali non entrano va bene
non bastava il lavoro che faccio tutti i
giorni per tenere pulita e in ordine
questa casa ci mancava solo il cane a
raddoppiare la mia mole di lavoro in
realtà sappiamo tutti che dopo qualche
giorno si innamorerà del cane e si
prenderà più cura del cane che di tutto
il resto della casa
un classico
e non sai cucinare e non sai lavare e non
sai stirare non sai fare niente guarda
poverino quello che ti sposa
proprio così povero quello che ti
sposerà perché avrà una suocera come me
e io nonostante tutto sono tua madre
quindi sarò sempre dalla tua parte
tanti auguri ascoltami è per il tuo bene
è semplicemente quello che ho deciso
cosa hai detto non ho capito bene faccio
finta di non aver sentito hai tre secondi
esatti per chiedermi scusa e rimangiarti
quello che hai detto senti a me non interessa che voto hanno preso gli altri va bene
ti devi impegnare di più perché io sono tua
madre e so che puoi fare di meglio
questa è l'ultima volta che te lo dico te
lo ripeterò per tutta la vita
e se lo trovo cosa succede come al
solito non hai cercato bene va bene a posto
fai quello che vuoi
non pensare minimamente di farlo se no
come ti ho creato ti distruggo eccoci
arrivati alla fine del video cari
maryners spero che vi sia piaciuto e mi
raccomando fatemi sapere con un commento
qua sotto quali frasi dicono piú spesso
le vostre mamme e se non l'avete ancora
fatto
iscrivetevi subito al canale di maryna e
cliccate sulla campanella vicino al tasto
d'iscrizione e soprattutto seguitela su
tutti gli altri social quindi instagram
facebook e tiktok vi mando un
bacione
mi raccomando fate i bravi non ve lo
dico più
ciao